helpsters our goal is to hand out frozen
freeze pops to cool down the
neighborhood now who's got an idea oh
man yeah we want the neighborhood to
know we have freeze pops
so
we should tell the neighborhood we have
freeze pops but what if they cannot hear
us you know mother prim always says to
speak softly and carry a big megaphone
use a megaphone to make our voices
louder if we are going to give a freeze
pops we need freeze pups
yeah we do and that's job two make
freeze pups so how do we stop the freeze
pops from melting before we hand them
out
that is job three find a way to keep the
freeze pops cold i shall find the
megaphone to make our voices louder hmm
i'll make the freeze pops and i will
find a way to keep them cold fantastic
huh looks like everything's going great
nothing's going great what do you mean
mr prim i went to the megaphone room to
get a megaphone but when i got there it
was empty except for this
oh
huh
no
megaphones no problem we'll just make a
new megaphone
with what with the paper in your hand
you know the sign hmm just follow my
commands okay
okay okay first roll the paper into a
cone all right all right
okay and next tape the edges together
let's just use that tape the megaphones
used to hang up the sign right that idea
yeah great all right looks good and last
hold small end of your mouth and talk
[Music]
testing
my voice is louder oh yeah it is use a
megaphone to make our voices louder
check
um
cody yeah i
need your help in the kitchen okay right
behind
you so uh talk to me buddy bud every
time i try to make them it doesn't work
oh why don't you show me your sequins
okay
first pour the juice into the tray
[Music]
okay looking good
next add the stick
[Music]
hmm look at that just uh falls right
over yeah but in the picture they stand
straight up right well
looks like we got a debug that means
finding fix the problem right yeah so
the sticks keep falling over in the
juice huh well we need something to hold
them up but what oh hey you have a
plastic wrap
always okay then new sequins first pour
the juice into the trays i already did
that yeah you did
next cover the tray with plastic wrap
covering
[Music]
next add the sticks
[Music]
the plastic makes this stick stand up
yeah look at that now add the rest of
the sticks buddy bud
uh-huh
okay then put the tray in the freezer
okay
got this don't spill it don't spill
don't spill it don't spill it
you got it all right and last
we wait for the freeze pops to freeze
hmm what do we do while we wait i have a
hard time waiting huh
what if we make camel noises
well what does a camel sound like like
this
[Music]
oh we've been doing that a while uh
let's check the freeze pops huh okay
thank god wow mcfreeze pops check
i did my cody
follow me
i found a way to keep the freeze pops
cold you can put them in here
hello penguin
it is very cold oh heart i am so sorry
my instructions were not clear enough
they were not
no heart we need to keep the freeze pops
cold when we take them outside to the
neighbors oh like a cooler oh yeah i
have a cooler yeah
oh fantastic but it is full of snow
this is so great heart we can use the
snow to keep the freeze pops cold oh
yeah find a way to keep the freeze pops
cold check
all the jobs are done
[Music]
don't worry felix will be here with
freeze pop soon i'm telling you no he
won't he's going to his brother's
reunion frozen freeze pops
that sounds like the helpsters come on
let's go let's go oh get your frozen
freeze box yeah
freeze box here we go
much cooler
much cooler
thanks for your help help students
you're very welcome
we did it everybody yeah we did help
stars
[Music]